my favorite jerry moment is when you
switched out his potato soup with glue
and he didn't know
you're so cute when you're bullying babe
you know what emma's right this is mean
we are going to pick up jerry what no
it's christmas time don't you want to
eat good people not really never you can
come in if you do something nice for
jerry hey i already did something nice
for jerry i drove here to take him to
jerry dinner oh donna
you can come in
i feel that some structural changes
could really unlock this department's
potential jerry hmm i believe you are
capable of much more
i'm not nonsense look in the mirror
huh you are an intelligent charismatic
beautiful superhero i'm making you head
of public relations which means you'll
be leading the daily briefing sessions
excellent idea
ha ha guys really funny where's the real
banner we only had an hour so did i look
what i did
hey guys
jerry welcome back
oh really my gosh you should not have
gone to all this trouble oh it's no
trouble for our buddy here you go listen
today is jerry day we'll do whatever you
want to do anything at all honestly what
i would like to do is just him
everything go back to normal that sounds
good to me okay i believe you were going
to do a presentation yes sir i was i
will go set up okay
remember you guys no jokes no comments
nothing but support
he needs a lot of support
tom talking about a bra for a man
okay seriously that was the last one
so
as we know spring hunting season is upon
us
uh anyway here's the info about
the new licensing system
um jerry
i don't i don't think your computer is
plugged in i'm sorry guys
just got to power up first thing we
should have is
my graph about the season
what wait a minute no
that is not the graph that's a picture
from my vacation to muncie you went on a
vacation and you chose muncie indiana
yeah my wife and i have a timeshare
is in muncie tom muncie is a lovely city
anyway hunting and fishing season is
winding down okay we all know that it's
already closed season on twelfth so now
i said twelve instead of trout
it happens to everyone my marbles are
full of mouth today
you know what has anybody
seen my glasses i don't even think i can
[Music]
[Applause]
well hello again you ready to be nice to
jerry because
it's so cold out here it reminds me of
my wife's lasagna
i actually like that one hey guys i
thought you weren't coming i nope never
got your rsvp hi jerry we got you a gift
merry christmas
yeah just so we took up a collection to
pay your hospital bills since you almost
farted yourself to death every time we
did something mean put a dollar in a box
wow
i'm the luckiest man on earth
okay well come on in it's a party
oh geez wow thanks guys this is really
this is really great okay i want
everyone to go around and tell their
favorite jerry story
[Laughter]
a positive one
who's first
jerry today is your birthday but
it's about much more than that it's also
about ann and i getting back together
and being the hottest couple in pawnee
i'd also like to announce our official
relationship mashup name
it's tan
tatan i would like to announce that the
name tan is officially over to the end
of tan
havrickens it is okay donna i would like
to address the fact that rule number
seven says
no pets and yet there is a three-legged
animal in my living room ron uh jerry's
work
is often adequate
i'll go
jerry has a wife and three beautiful
daughters a full life and that's amazing
let's see i really appreciate this but i
did prime my scale i would leave by five
she has a tasty surprise waiting for me
if you know what i mean gross jerry she
made a meatloaf well this is better than
meatloaf when jerry first applied for
this job one of his goals was to have a
building named after him again that is
an absurd request considering your work
record but i thought maybe he could have
a room named after him
so henceforth parks and rec conference
room will serve as a testament to your
years of public service oh my come here
jerry gerget's memorial conference room
r.i.p um oh the guy at the black store
thought you had died it was a rush job
so we didn't have time to change it
doesn't matter we can just pretend it
means retire in peace
yeah okay so bring out the cake oh
speech speech speech
well thank you guys not much of a speech
maker but i do like good cake
uh
you're on fire
oh my god
well that went roughly as well as i
thought it would
promise gail i'd leave at five i guess
this is it
bye
see you tomorrow jeremy
jerry i wanted to say i'm sorry that i
screwed up your birthday party oh that's
okay but we all pitched in and we are
sending you and gail to a b b in your
favorite place in the world
muncie
amazingly yes muncie indiana oh thank
you guys it was really expensive sorry
sorry you guys i'm sorry i'm trying to
find my inhaler cause i'm having a
little take your time i mean it's not
like we're trying to get work done here
yeah and larry by the way you're looking
the wrong spot your inhaler is hidden
under the pile of pistachio shells on my
desk obviously well that's funny cause
i'm terribly allergic to pistachios
classic okay you know what i need to say
something
i like larry
he is a good friend and a fine man with
an
inexplicably gorgeous wife i mean to the
point where it makes no sense at all
sorry getting off track he's a nice
person and we should all stand up and
say
i
like ben no what are you doing uh he's
embarrassing himself and throwing away
his career sweetheart stop oh captain my
captain what is happening larry is my
friend
thank you
ben mean that
[Music]
got so startled i tooted come on man
gross
you know i met gail right here at
sherm's
she was slender blonde hair big brass
long legs oh that might try for all and
what was it exactly that led to you two
hitting it off was she ill
or did your father witness her father
committing a crime or was she tempted
you know what all that matters is you
got married and you're happy so as
all-time best man i suggest we raise a
cone to jerry gergich
thank you
who's gary oh i think that's supposed to
be me
ha ha that's your new name gary gary
gary gary gary
gary is my real name yes after 30 years
my co-workers are finally going to call
me by my real name
oh boy i'm blessed
who is gonna be the mayor for the next
two months then
gary gergich
how would you like to be the next mayor
of pawnee indiana
what the hell is all this about you'll
see
well
i gotta say that was a heck of a lot of
fun
[Music]
what's on earth i pray for someone happy
inauguration day buddy
oh jeez leslie
[Music]
the passing of our beloved mayor
gunderson
marks the end of an era but we are about
to begin a new chapter in pawnee's
history
ladies and gentlemen
the new mayor of the great city of
pawnee indiana gary gergich
i just want to say
[Applause]
me
you